querido público y siendo fieles a
nuestro compromiso con la diversidad y
la diversión que marcan este evento ted
ex al coi 2019 vamos a realizar el aviso
de apertura del acto en lenguaje
internacional de signos para su total
comprensión para todas las personas que
nos vean tanto en directo como por las
redes gracias por su atención
comenzamos
faltan cinco minutos para qué
comienza el espectáculo
le rogamos
les rogamos encarecidamente
desconecten y desconecten desconecten
las canciones de sones de las canciones
de skate tengo
así de gente la voz es con este en la
voz después en la voz de los teléfonos
así desconectar a otros teléfonos para
para no
y molestar no molestar
con mariposas
dragones
fantasmas monstruos con monstruos no
impone aparecido por el ping pong entre
exponentes con entesa para no molestar
no molestar a los ponentes sino teléfono
no para no molestar
el té el té
el té
ay nos alegramos
we
hoy voy a pasar hoy
que es cortado
no
xx el té el té ex el té
el té de excel te dé el sí
el té de c's
para de jong aviso para que yo los
invita el télex os invita hoy a
disfrutar y aprender
de los oradores míralos ahí están ahí
otros oradores
nos van a dar a los oradores nos van a
dar una botella no una bebida los
oradores nos van a dar una botella
abierta no nos van a dar la chapa pues
van a dar a chapa no la charla la charla
la chapa no o la charla
sobre un sobre
alta alta sensibilidad share ciencia
también nos van a decir algo sobre
ciencia hoy hoy hoy hoy cuánto ambiente
cuánto ambiente hay medio medio ambiente
vale medio ambiente también vamos a
hacer hoy es sobre arte también vamos a
hablar
hoy hoy hoy este círculo no está bien
aparcado no a nada no
se va a enterar este circuito a la toma
multa a la siguiente marketing artículo
poli polis poli polis amor de poliamor
vale poliamor también vamos a hablar que
me cuesta pero pero ojo ojo ojo pequeño
hijo pequeño ojito ojito
si yo yo sí y si yo veo a vosotros
[Música]
un cabreo me mienta mala leche mala
leche me entra mala leche y empieza a
repartir empieza a repartir vez de
repartir empieza a repartir hostias
empieza a repartir hostias os de pim pam
pum pam pim pam pum así por filas
como panes como panes ipad
me quedo solo me quedo solo repartiendo
i
vaqueros de los vaqueros duelo para que
nos duela feo feo
pero sí está claro feo y malo malo el
bueno el feo y el malo bueno bueno bueno
bueno bueno yo me piro
es un momento yo me piro llevan pelotas
a mi bola yo a mi bola yo mi bola pero
yo me voy me voy no me voy voy a estar
ahí
espiando
no sé si yo veo que este ya tiene
molestando adicción tonto
aquí
al canto al canto
gracias ahora sí